una visita del precedente selensky a las
tropas del Don Baz para conmemorar el
Día de las fuerzas armadas ucranianas
entendemos que no es fácil para nuestras
fuerzas armadas en ninguna dirección
porque están luchando contra un ejército
cuyo Rango en el mundo ni siquiera
conozco sin embargo sé que nuestras
tropas especialmente en el este son las
más fuertes porque la situación en esta
región es la más difícil es nada
además aprovechó para visitar a los
soldados heridos en combate Los
ucranianos han logrado avances en la
recuperación del control sobre regiones
que estuvieron bajo dominio ruso como en
el caso de gersón mientras Moscú
concentra su artillería sobre bakmut
para intentar hacerse con ella a pesar
de la ofensiva y contraofensiva los
ejércitos de los dos países hicieron un
nuevo intercambio de 60 prisioneros de
cada bando ellos esperan regresar pronto
a casa
mamá tía Hola a todos Saludos en doníes
todo va bien Estoy vivo y sano pronto
estaré en casa nos han recibido bien
ambos países han intercambiado más de
mil prisioneros de guerra en tanto las
embajadas de Ucrania siguen recibiendo
cartas bomba y con objetos amenazantes
según lo denuncia el ministro de
exteriores culeva mae Villa
a todos los que siguen enviando estos
paquetes y aterrorizando a nuestras
embajadas les pido que se tranquilicen y
no malgasten su tiempo y dinero en
sellos de correos no conseguirán nada
las misiones diplomáticas de varios
países europeos han recibido paquetes
con ojos de animales y recubiertos de un
líquido color acre nadie ha reivindicado
los envíos